move over Kourtney Kim khloé Kendall and
Kylie there's a new Kardashian going
viral on the internet well a Kardashian
adjacent person I'm really freaking out
it was kind of a freak out moment for me
meet Natalie's ëtil yep a member of the
extended kardashian-jenner family named
so excited Natalie is the only daughter
of kris Jenner's younger sister Karen
and while she's just now gaining some
internet fame she's been hanging with
the famous fam this whole time it's
really lit and fine and crazy on
Thanksgiving she posted up with her mom
and grandma MJ that's right the og
matriarch of the reality TV fam I was I
was pretty cool kind of cool yeah and if
that weren't proof enough natalie also
caught up with her cousin kylie
snuggling up for this festive pic next
to a giant Christmas tree in what
appears to be Chris's house she
captioned the pic quote love ya back in
August
Nathalie joined MJ Kim and Kim's
daughter North for a tour of the White
House hosting this group pic in front of
a portrait of George Washington I love
that and here she is that same month
again with north and MJ Natalie also
attended a k'kaw Beauty event posing
with her famous aunt and cousin and
fitting right in with the family's
signature photo booth lighting how are
you gonna write know your angle you have
to know you know the lighting is
everybody and here she is supporting her
cousins in some Kendall and Kylie undies
I mean it's awesome I just
we're lucky to be surrounded by amazing
people after getting a ton of attention
online fans quickly started comparing
her to her famous cousins with lots of
people saying she resembles Kylie and
Kendall
[Music]